PROFESSOR: OK, so our
discussion at the beginning
was based on just
taking the state,
those instantaneous
energy island states,
and calculating what phases
would make it satisfy
the Schrodinger equation.
And we found those
are the phases that
came close to satisfying
the Schrodinger equation,
but not quite.
So in order to do this under a
more controlled approximation,
let's do a calculation where
we put all the information in.
So if you have a
state psi of t, we'll
write it as a
superposition of states
of instantaneous eigenstates.
So this is a general solution.
Maybe general [? an ?]
[? sets ?] for a solution.
The wave function-- since
those instantaneous energy
eigenstates are
complete orthonormal,
this form a ON basis,
orthonormal basis at all
times--
at any time, it's an
orthonormal set of states--
we should be able to write our
state as that superposition.
So what we're going
to do is now kind
of re-do the analysis of the
[INAUDIBLE] approximation
more generally so that we see,
in fact, equations that show up
that you can solve in general.
So the Schrodinger equation
is i h bar dvt of psi
is equal to H psi.
So let's look at what
it gives us here.
So we'll have i
h bar sum over n.
And I have to
differentiate this state.
So we get Cn dot--
dot for time derivatives--
psi n plus Cn psi n dot--
this is a time derivative
of this state--
is equal to H of psi--
this is the sum over n Cn of t--
H of psi n, is equal
to E n of t psi n of t.
OK, so that's your equation.
Now let's see in various
components what it gives you.
So to see the various
components, we form an overlap
with a psi k of t.
So we'll bring in a psi k of t.
And what do we get?
Since these states
are orthonormal,
psi k, when it comes here,
this is a function of time.
It doesn't care.
Psi k hits a psi n.
That's a Kronecker delta.
The sum disappears.
And the only term that
is left here is Ck dot.
So we get i h bar Ck
dot from this term.
And let's put the second
term to the right hand side.
So let's just write what we
get from the right hand side
and from this term.
So from the right
hand side, we have
the psi k on that thing
that is on the right.
That, again, hits this state
and produces a Kronecker delta.
So we get Ck Ek of
t from the term that
was on the right hand side.
And here, however, we
don't get rid of the sum
because psi k is not
orthonormal to psi n dot.
Psi n dot is more complicated.
So what do we get here?
Minus i h bar the sum over n psi
k psi n dot inner product Cn.
OK, that's pretty
close to what we want.
But let's write it still in
a slightly different way.
I want to isolate the Ck's.
So from that sum, I will
separate the Ck part.
So we'll have Ek of t.
And there's going to be a term
here, when we have n equal k,
so I'll bring it out there--
minus i h bar psi k psi k dot
Ck.
And the last term
now becomes i h bar
the sum over n different
from k psi k psi n dot Cn.
OK, so this is the form
of the equation that
is nice and gives you a
little understanding of what's
going on.
That's a general
treatment of trying
to make a solution from
instantaneous energy
eigenstates.
Here were your instantaneous
energy eigenstates.
We tried to make a solution.
That is the full equation.
What did we do before?
We used just one of them.
We took one instantaneous
energy eigenstate
and we tried to make a solution
by multiplying by one thing,
and then we tried.
But then it doesn't
work because when
you have just one coefficient,
say k, with some fixed k,
you have this equation.
But then you couple to
all other coefficients
where n is different from k.
So what we did before
was essentially,
by claiming that
this term is small,
just focus on this
thing, and this
is an easily solvable
equation that,
in fact, gives the type
of solution we have there.
When you have C
dot equal to this--
I'll write it in our
previous approximation,
so in the approximation where
the last term is negligible.
And we would see why
it could be negligible.
Then we get just i
h bar Ck dot equals
Ek of t minus i h bar
psi k psi k dot Ck.
And this thing is solved
by writing Ck of t
is equal to e to the 1 over
i h bar integral from 0 to t
of this whole thing Ek of t
prime minus i h bar psi k psi k
dot of t prime dt
prime times Ck of 0.
This is a differential equation.
So i h bar times the
time derivative of this--
if you apply a i h
bar time derivative,
you differentiate with respect
to time, then exponent,
you get 1 over i h bar
that cancels this i h bar.
And the derivative of the
exponent is this factor--
just this standard, first order,
time dependent differential
equation.
So last time we said we
ignored possible couplings
between the different modes
represented by this term,
and we just solved
this equation,
which gave us this, which
is exactly what we've
been writing here.
e to the I theta of k
comes from the first term
on that integral.
And e to the i gamma of k
comes from the second term
on that integral.
These are the same things.
So what is new here is
that there is a coupling.
And you cannot assume that
just Ck evolves in time some
particular k, and
the others don't.
The others will get coupled.
In particular, if you have
that at time equals 0--
t equals 0-- some Ck
of 0 is equal to 1,
but all the other
ones, Ck primes at 0,
are equal to 0 for all k
prime different from k,
so your initial condition is
you are in the state k at time
equals 0.
That's why you have Ck at time
equals [? 0 to ?] [? a 1. ?]
And the others are 0
at different times.
If you look at your
differential equation
and try to see what happens
after a little time, well,
we know Ck dot is
going to change,
is going to have a
non-trivial value.
This is going to happen.
But these things are
not going to remain 0.
Those other states are
going to get populated,
in particular, i h
bar Ck prime dot.
Look at the top equation.
Apply for k equal to k prime
and look at time equals 0.
What do you get
at time equals 0?
Well, you would get
all these factor--
Ek prime times Ck
prime at time equals 0.
Well, that's 0.
That's nothing.
But from the last term,
what would we get?
Minus i h bar sum over n
different from k prime of psi k
prime psi n dot Cn
at time equals 0.
And here, well, the only
one that is different from 0
at time equals 0 is Ck.
And k, when n is
equal to k, is allowed
because we said k prime
is different from k.
So there is one term here.
This is minus i h bar
psi k prime psi k dot.
Only when n equals to k
you get something here
because this is the
only term that exists.
And it's equal to 1.
So immediately, at time equals
0, the other coefficients start
changing.
You start populating the
other instantaneous energy
eigenstates.
So there is real mixing
in this top thing that
says it's not rigorous to claim
that you stay in that energy
eigenstate.
It starts to couple.
And if it starts to
couple, then eventually you
make transitions.
The only hope, of course, is
that that term is really small.
And basically, we can
argue how that term
becomes a little small by
doing a little calculation.
And then we can be rigorous
and take a long time
to get to the conclusion,
or we can just state it.
And that's what we're
going to do after analyzing
that term a little more.